for
this arm you have to pass to the
inside don't have this arm hugging
around
you this arm by passing
it's like just like
this it's not much different than the
beginning move to an
arm it's coming in
not the
arm okay let's get that pass
okay I am not trying to hit him and then
he leans back because he's supposed to
reconcile my
strike that would be a young young
class nor am I trying to bend him
over like this and then he falls because
he's
acrobatic what I am
doing is tilting his body
you're going to feel the Y of his
standing inertia and his forward inertia
so I have to take the forward inertia
and Yin yield it like
that okay not here and shove it
back I it's going to go forward and
around and then
[Music]
back
forward around
then I'm going to take it this
way once I take it that
way my body comes in it takes his
base the other
way to keep him in that pattern my whole
body is going to
adhere to any part I'm touching Okay so
so over
here go over here go on this side
please I have his inner hand touching me
his
forearm the knife edge my
forearm all of this I adhere to by
matching the Y value okay I'm match the
Y
value I'm not shoving
his I want his whole body in the
tech there's the
heel and I adhere that moves
him the back foot is my grounding foot
so all the I
key and the C at the
bottom is on the back foot so do not
Rudder the back foot
[Music]
okay try it okay the weight distribution
on the
EDI don't even go to
6040 more
here okay
5540 so I'm not going to
go into this s
[Music]
right
5248 can out a little
turn got more
hey try
okay so in the last Technique we were
doing the backward
position this this
way this one we're doing the back
outward
position this way but the falling
geometry is exactly the same okay so I'm
going to come ad
here and let him go wait out don't move
I'll move you and I make him go in this
circle
the circle starts at the Tachi then I
make contact here and I keep it going
back this
way is that adhesion on the upper
arm don't make him
go that
way because you're not trying to bend
them
over you're going to tilt in towards you
you're going to make him go this way and
then you're entering across
here I'm not knocking him down just like
in the other technique in this technique
I'm not throwing him down with my arm
this arm is bringing him this way and
then it stays with
him there's nothing on my arm at that
point same thing here I'm not up here
and I'm trying to shove him down I'm
trying not to shove him down Okay so
this part this leg comes in and he going
to attack a little
lower for my height for
him on the inside one I wor a little
higher on the leg on this glue part
they try again